I'm Patrick with your host evalute
imminent you ever hear people and all
these books that we read saying you know
I hire for these qualities and this
other guy says I hired for those
qualities and these go and then
eventually we have a book 40 different
reasons to hire somebody for so what
quality is what and so to me over the
last 10 years from making so many
mistakes on hiring and firing people
I've come up with four things that I
hire for and this is so interesting
because this conversation came up this
morning with our staff and I asked them
I said what would you say I'd hire four
and they literally said every one of the
things that I hire for now covered with
you here in a second so think about it
this way when when you're in business
and you're new on business it's
typically very easy to hire people and
you have a very hard time firing people
because you're emotionally attached to
be afraid of fire somebody right so easy
to hire hard to fire the longer you're
in business it actually becomes harder
for you to hire somebody because you're
picky and choosey who you're going to
put your time on to and it's very easy
to fire people because you actually
don't fire that many people people if
you do this properly you're not firing
that many people it's either they don't
become part of the environment which is
a small percentage because you've
learned how to hire or life happens and
they end up having to walk away because
life happens so let me talk to you about
the four things that I look for when I'm
hiring somebody number one on my list is
love let me explain why number one is on
my list to me love is very important I
look for someone who loves the company
who loves a vision that you're casting
I'm casting loves a crusade that that
their heart starts connecting with it
because if if you can hi my experience
has been if you can hire people based on
love you don't need to have work ethic
on a list because love is an action in
my opinion if love is an action and the
definition of love to you is also an
action it's a verb then that means
everything from love work ethic comes
because of love so if someone loves they
can have a work ethic if parents make
food for their kids three meals a day
not because they have to
they love and they put the time to cook
if you know parents put the time to drop
off the kids in the morning and pick
them up and work so hard and do this and
do that love it doesn't there's no
manual that says you got to work hard
when you're a parent no the manual is
you'll love they have a place in your
heart
so you work so I hired based on love so
and another thing would love is this is
what to keep in mind I don't you can't
force somebody to love you your vision
your company can do it and if you
constantly are trying to force somebody
to love you it's kind of like the guy
who's in love with this girl and he
loves her so much but she doesn't love
him she likes him and you know she
tolerates him and all his life he's
trying to earn her love and she's just
not gonna love him she doesn't love him
she just likes him you know they're just
together because it's good they don't
this guy has all his life and that can
be very draining
I don't hire for forcing somebody to
love if you love it we're gonna work to
get if you don't no problem you're gonna
find a place that you're gonna love and
we're gonna find people that were gonna
hired are we gonna love is one that's
okay
the second point that I look for is my
buddy Jose this morning came and trained
some of our staff and he said you know
how his business has been growing very
fast because his team's level of trust
is at the highest it's ever been he says
Pat the way we trust one another right
now it's something else I've never seen
her like this before
you know everybody's trusting each other
and I remember one of my good friends
George asked me maybe nine years ago he
said hey Patrick what's the number-one
thing you look for at that time for a
friend and I said trust to me is very
important trust and loyalty to me is
very very important and Trust is
something that it doesn't happen
overnight so when when I hire somebody
you're not going to be working with them
I'm gonna put time into working with
this individual the trust may take a
little bit the trust may take three six
months right trusted I remember what
Mark Cuban said in Dallas he said when I
hire new talent I micromanage them until
I trust them and it's not necessarily
micromanaging I think it's more
monitoring setting expectations seeing
what they're doing
accountable until more and more you're
letting go letting go letting on that
boom you can let them do it because
trust levels that is that in high
all-time high and then that person doing
business with you based on your
consistencies and your habits and them
seeing that you are true to your vision
to your cause the level of trust from
your new team member goes higher and
higher and a higher the level of trust
it's very easy environment to do
business with and that goes right into
numbers three number three is speed
speed is important because you know
you'll hear people say well you know
would you rather have somebody that
works very fast but they're not very
efficient or have somebody that's very
efficient but very slow and my answer is
I want both I want speed and efficiency
and I think that's out there you know I
think it's an excuse when people say you
can't find speed and efficiency at the
same time I think I think there's plenty
of people that are fast and efficient at
the same time it's really expectation
and it's you know time management that
that person's got to work on but if I'm
working with somebody that's got speed
especially in a startup environment if
you're on Aronica startup it's very very
important to have the kind of an
environment where there's deadlines
there's typically a lot faster deadlines
in a start-up environment and a company
that's been on for 50 years the company
that's been around for 50 years they
don't have a lot of fast deadlines but
let me also tell you a company that's
been on for 50 years what they don't do
they also don't make decisions quickly
it may take them six months to make a
decision but their deadline also may be
three months where deadlines in the
startup company maybe a week or maybe
tomorrow at five o'clock but the point
is the deadlines in the startup it's a
lot faster so speed becomes very
important the last one to me you know it
you know kind of solves all three
problems the first three that loves
trust and speed the last one is very
simple I love working with people who
are purely committed to improvement if
I'm working with somebody who is not
good in a certain area but they come
back as a pad I promise you give me two
to four weeks look how good I'll be I'll
show it to you two weeks or not no
problem that shows me that person is
committed to beating their prior best
personal development growing getting
better there is nothing like working
with a group
people that are constantly working on
getting better you know one of the
things I started I run a book club
international book club is called the
entrepreneur book club on YouTube but
I've been running a book club with my
staff for five years and here's what we
do every month I recommend a book and a
team the entire staff goes and reads the
book and then once a month we get
together we sit at the conference room
and we go through tell me what you got
out of the book tell me what you got out
of the book and everybody goes to what
how about this how about that how could
you apply that to the business how could
you do this how could you do that how
about this how about this and we have
seen people where three years ago were
frightened of certain things to work on
I can't tell you how incredible they are
today conflicts between two people that
they couldn't work together they are
best friends now running together as a
team you know somebody who was afraid of
speaking in front of an audience or
calling on people or business they have
improved to a whole different level
because they have committed to personal
development they have committed to
constant getting better so if I find
somebody who loves what they do with us
the company to brand a vision to crusade
if they are trusting and they trust
because you got to have both it's very
hard when you work somebody that doesn't
trust and it's very hard you work with
somebody that you don't trust them Trust
is their speed is automatically going to
go to a whole different level and you
have personal development which
eventually leads to efficiency you have
a winner there you find somebody with
those four you put your time and
resources into it because that could be
somebody a long-term that your time is
not going to be wasted because they're
not going to be going anywhere because
they love what they do you don't need to
tell them to work because they love what
they do they're trusting and you trust
them and they trust you
speeds in the right place as well as
working on themselves improvement if you
give them a challenge they going to work
on it together with you that's a
long-term person to invest your time
into now you may have some ideas on what
you like to hire for I would love to
hear it please comment on the bottom if
you have any questions about what I
talked about also comment on the bottom
and last but not least please
we should have subscribed to this
channel thanks for watching
you